hi i'm jay cohen author of the cookbook
jewish and this is pro tips from pro
chefs
[Music]
so i've become pretty well known for my
challah and i get tons of questions all
the time about like how to make a better
loaf of bread and it really isn't that
much work it's only five ingredients but
it does require a ton of tlc
my go-to tips always start with kneading
the dough when you knead your dough it
really can take a punch people are
afraid that they're going to overwork it
that's impossible you really need to put
in so much effort to build up this
gluten which is going to give you that
structure and then after that the second
tip is proofing
[Music]
this is letting the dough double in size
you are activating all that yeast it
starts to eat the sugar and the honey in
the recipe
and
time you have to be patient people are
so impatient and they're like oh the
recipe says it says an hour at the end
of the day that time is going to change
every time you make it depending on the
humidity the temperature the weather
where you are in the country all of
these are going to affect so really it's
all about the visual cues when it
doubles its size you're ready to move on
and last but not least if you want a
really really really shiny challah i
always go for a double egg wash so you
brush your hollow right before the
second proof and right before it goes
into the oven and that gives you that
beautiful sheen and you're gonna have
like people are gonna go crazy when they
see this claw
[Music]
some of the common problems i find are a
people love to to substitute we're like
oh i didn't want to use any sugar so i
used all honey and that's going to
change the recipe completely because of
the fact that honey's obviously liquid
and you have to make adjustments same
thing with flour if you use all whole
wheat flour you are going to end up with
a brick so they're really fun ways that
you can tweak and incorporate but every
time you make a change you have to pivot
if you start to add in some whole wheat
flour or some rye flour or any anything
you really want to add in terms of
flavoring
you really want to make sure that you
adjust the rest of the recipe and and
that really comes down to like when
you're kneading you're looking for a
tacky not sticky dough if your dough is
sticky it's not going to end well so
really like enough flour just to get
that beautiful play-doh-esque quality
you are such an expert at braiding
challah getting the braid right is
something that is harder than it seems
you know if you follow the step by step
and really are detail-oriented and you
get that braid right i think it makes a
huge difference it's only four moves
that you just repeat and really like
sometimes when we do it together i will
just like we're like i think of vikings
like the eve
i'll just tell them second from the lot
right all the way over front right to
the center second yeah so so really just
like say it out loud and you're gonna
it's like a mantra
it's a mantra for more pro tips you can
head to the drewbarrymore show.com
protips and if you do bake any challah
be sure to tag me at jay cohen and use
the hashtag drewbarrymore show
[Music]